he'll there ain't no beavers that is a
big kill guys I didn't get to this set I
got tied up doing some other things the
weather got cold everything froze right
right back to the full thickness of the
ice and I didn't want to leave these
snares in there even though they really
couldn't have caught anything the way
they were I didn't want to leave these
snares in here like this so I want to
get this thing out you know now that
this hole is open if I can get this
pillowcase out of here I can reset it
and then I can I can check it again it's
probably about a 800 pound chunk ice
go ahead
hey God and boy who that's about the
hardest beaver trapping I ever had to
deal with that's kind of interesting
it's definitely beaver choose at the
bottom of the ice here you're in here so
they cook after this froze down to the
bottom they these sticks are sticking
down into the water and they cute it
right up to the level of the ice here
that's a good sign there's definitely
something something in here
maybe this moment I'm going to work for
nothing after all I have another leg
hold set which would be fairly easy to
pop down here pretty quick it's
sensitive
bring kill mode now put the baby down in
there he made one mistake he came in he
kept some of my base and left the
evidence